the gyro can experience I mean that's a
real thought with imagine being a guy
like Harvey Weinstein who was doing this
for so long get away with all his [ __ ]
up [ __ ] for so long support supported by
support supported support I mean he had
a clause in its contract detailing what
would happen for the first case of
sexual harassment second case supported
A's in the contract so why don't why are
there [ __ ] why are they help why why why
aren't the people that support him up a
Cheeto um I'd love you to join my
podcast network I'm thinking about
promoting you been I just think you're a
great guy you're a funny guy your
talented guy thought I think you might
be a raper
so what I want to put is a first rape
I'm gonna charge you this much again
second what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] imagine
the first sexual harassment is I got a
figure and the second one lawsuit has
another figure us a double the figure
they're like three strikes you're out
but it's not something he can't afford
now it's like two fifty five hundred
grand he's like a billionaire yeah he's
Harvey wines he goes fine he made pulp
fiction yeah yeah he's eating food while
they're talking it's [ __ ] crumbs all
down his face he's drunk enough other
talk button this is the glutton a filthy
fat [ __ ] glutton you can't make a
better case for a glutton than that guy
he's a metaphor for the business by the
way all consuming taking right and look
though yeah he he would he would ruin
what's beautiful right take was
beautiful he broke pretty soon mouth was
fat gut resting on their forehead he
[ __ ] he ruined pretty things yeah
he farted pretty things horrible [ __ ]
that guy but it's interesting because
like that is a villain in a movie he's
like oh he's a villain in a movie yes
it's like a like a bad Dick Tracy
guarantee well you know no no more
modern he's a feeling that he's a
villain more you know [ __ ] Harvey
Weinstein movie is what he is
oh yeah someone will make that film he's
a villain and no but he's a villain in a
Quentin Tarantino movie right if there
was a guy who was doing dark [ __ ] and
then one of the girls winds up playing
like some kickass female character ones
I've shooting him and killing them
except Hannah what the [ __ ] your name
who the woman who's in Kill Bill not
luma Thurman but the Daryl here Daryl
Hannah yeah Daryl Hannah Daryl Hannah
wants up kill him tight like it kills
him with a brick Oh plus his [ __ ]
head open
yeah like Patricia Arquette when she
killed Tony Soprano yes remember yes
right yeah yeah yeah she was del [ __ ]
yeah yeah that was perfect he was the
perfect character that Tony Soprano
character that she killed when James
Gandolfini and true romance when it was
a Patricia Arquette to Arquette's
well know what's the other Arquette it's
to our cats
oh no no no pressure okay it was
Patricia but there's no no as a girl
there's another girl there yes yes no no
there is I'm crap don't you shake your
head [ __ ] there was no you there she's
dead
oh [ __ ] yeah which one well bro you
better not be wrong so that's even worse
it's bad if you miss Jamie Rosen's an
art yes oh [ __ ] she's been a gang of
movies too she was in Pulp Fiction well
yes well Rosanna Arquette was in Pulp
Fiction she was uh wasn't she one of the
chick she was a part of like when a girl
of any Barbarino had over the girl
overdose that was her they had a helper
yeah that was her that she would she was
helping Huma Thurmond she was the girl
too had [ __ ] all over her face as he
said did she goes your wife has [ __ ] all
over he goes who's the girl with the
[ __ ] all over her face and he goes
that's my wife and he's like oh [ __ ]
were they like piercings or something
yeah yeah yeah she appears things right
wasn't it right he goes he goes who's
that he goes how's the chick with [ __ ]
all over he goes that's my [ __ ] wife
what a movie man what a [ __ ] movie
anyway
easily one of the best films forever a
made always amazing movie but Patricia
Arquette and true romance right when she
killed James Gandolfini like that's
she's killing the glutton she's killing
the big disgusting yeah [ __ ] man yeah
a big [ __ ] shitty man doesn't have a
[ __ ] about women and he's gonna kill her
but she [ __ ] she [ __ ] kills him he
like
yes blood coming down her face it's
crazy [ __ ] is dope
that's great [ __ ] scene is
[Applause]